[Music]
what is the relation a relation gives us
a set of ordered pairs that satisfy a
relationship let's understand this using
an example of two sets we have two sets
P and Q set peas has elements 2 & 4 and
set Q has elements 10 20 and 35 we first
take the Cartesian product of the two
sets let's use an arrow diagram for the
Cartesian product of sets P and Q so P
cross Q is a set of the following
ordered pairs it's two paired with each
of these three and then four paired with
each of these three we get six ordered
pairs of the form P comma Q where every
P belongs to set P and every Q belongs
to set Q that's how it can be written in
the set builder form now let's introduce
a relation our relation R gives us a set
of all ordered pairs that satisfy a
relation it could be any relation now
suppose we introduce a relation R - such
that Q is a multiple of P so we can say
that relation R - gives us a set of all
ordered pairs P comma Q where Q is the
multiple of P every ordered pair in the
set R - satisfies the relation R - this
is the set builder method to represent
our - please note that Q has to be a
multiple of P here now let's choose
ordered pairs from a Cartesian product B
cross Q that satisfies the relation R -
this is the ordered pairs in the
Cartesian product noticed such 10 is a
multiple of 220 is a multiple of two and
20 is a multiple of four so we get the
ordered pairs 2 comma 10 - comma 20 and
4 comma 20 such that every ordered pair
satisfies the relation Q is a multiple
of P this is the roster method to
represent set R - roster
list so we can say that the ordered
pairs in set are - are all listed like
in a roster set are - can also be
represented using an arrow diagram we
draw an arrow for every ordered pair in
set R - so we draw one arrow for 2 comma
10 another arrow for 2 comma 20 and
another arrow for 4 comma 20 let's say
this entire circle represents the set of
elements in the Cartesian product P
cross Q in that case set R - will be a
part of it we can say that set R dash is
a subset of the Cartesian product P
cross Q that's the basic concept of a
relation a relation gives us a set of
ordered pairs that satisfy a
relationship
you